y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
aquí en france 24 para ello me acompaña
el estudio daniel hablando daniela
bienvenida la comisión europea puso la
lupa sobre las cripto monedas hola raúl
pues mire el ejecutivo comunitario lanzó
la propuesta de crear en 2023 una
agencia para mejorar la lucha contra el
blanqueo de capitales a su vez se
comprometió por primera vez a vigilar
las empresas que manejan activos
virtuales como por ejemplo las cripto
monedas que con esta norma estarían
sujetas a estrictas reglas contra el
lavado de dinero pues cada vez son más
usadas para financiar todo tipo de
actividades ilícitas esto hizo que el
bilkoin la moneda o la cripto moneda más
grande del mundo cayera por debajo de
los 30 mil dólares por primera vez en un
mes
y nuestras leyes anti blanqueo de
capitales ahora están entre las más
estrictas del mundo pero todavía no se
aplican de esa forma y hay vacíos
legales en nuestros sistemas financieros
que debemos cerrar también debemos
coordinarnos mejor entre países de la
unión europea para luchar contra el
crimen transfronterizo fueran soca en
todo caso raúl la última palabra la
tienen los estados miembros de la unión
europea así como el parlamento ya así
que de eso podría tomar unos dos años
daniela hablemos ahora de la hazaña del
viaje espacial de diez besos que habrá
un paso una nueva industria bueno pues
el multimillonario dueño de amazon el
más rico del mundo según la revista
forbes viajó este martes al espacio
después de que también lo hiciera el
afortunado richard branson poco más de
una semana antes el dueño de tesla elon
musk no tarda en unirse también a este
grupo este es el primer paso para que en
un futuro no muy lejano el turismo
interestelar sea de masas
richard branson fundador
versión grupo creó en 2004 virgin
galactic para ofrecer viajes comerciales
en aeronaves de carga por un precio que
hasta ahora va entre 200 y 250 mil
dólares su propuesta es distinta a la de
besòs y más que con blue o vergini space
sex respectivamente en lugar de aviones
han optado por enviar cohetes el banco
suizo v/s estima que el turismo espacial
será una industria de tres mil millones
de dólares al año
besòs ha dicho que ya tiene unos 100
millones de dólares en ventas privadas
de hecho uno de sus asientos para el
viaje del martes se subastó por 28
millones de dólares y habría que ver
daniela también el impacto ambiental
porque parece que puede dañar entonces
esto la capa de ozono seguimos un
crítico de las grandes tecnologías es
ahora su nuevo supervisor pues el
presidente joe biden designó a un
destacado crítico de las nuevas
tecnologías para encabezar la división
antimonopolio del departamento de
justicia de eeuu esta es otra señal de
movimientos agresivos para contrarrestar
el dominio
de las principales empresas de silicon
valley se trata de jonathan cantera
quien según la casa blanca ha sido un
destacado defensor y experto en el
esfuerzo por promover una política de
competencia también ha abogado por la
aplicación de la legislación
antimonopolio cantera ha sido bien
conocido por representar a rivales de
google en procesos de competencia y su
designación definitiva depende ahora del
senado y con lo que presentó su nueva
reforma tributaria daniela sí señora el
gobierno del bando que presentó
oficialmente al congreso el proyecto con
el que espera recaudar cerca de cuatro
mil millones de dólares a pesar de que
este martes revivieron las protestas que
llevaron al ejecutivo a desistir de la
primera propuesta hace tres meses el
proyecto de ley aumentaría el impuesto
de renta a las empresas en cuatro puntos
porcentuales a partir de 2022 hasta el
35% y busca luchar contra elevación y
controlar el gasto estatal e insiste
también el gobierno en que no afectará a
los contribuyentes de menores ingresos
wall street consiguió anular buena parte
de las pérdidas que había tenido el
lunes por el temor de la propagación de
la variante delta del coronarios sus
principales índices avanzaron alrededor
del 16 por ciento y en américa latina'
el mayor incremento se vio en la bolsa
de buenos aires con más de 2% cuando el
gobierno emite deuda en el mercado local
y para finalizar sufre el día las
ganancias de la plataforma de streaming
netflix que pasaron los 3 mil millones
de dólares entre enero y junio de este
año se duplicaron con respecto al mismo
período del año pasado raúl y danny como
siempre gracias por toda la información
económica a ustedes también gracias y
continúe con nosotros aquí en france24
porque hay mucho más para ver aquí en
nuestro canal
[Música]